good morning yeah you're so cute
good morning enjoy groceries are in the
fridge awesome because I hate grocery
shopping running errands to places where
you have to like get the kids in and out
of the car sometimes a complete and
total nightmare when you have three
children so it'd be nice to have these
errands run typically I put myself
second asking somebody to do personal
things for you and being involved kind
of your private life is is very intimate
what did you want to get done to I have
some bills to pay
been driving around with the stuff in my
car that needs to be donated maybe an
appointment or two for my wife preparing
dinner for her is like something that is
very important what's up guys how's it
going good anybody up for a water fight
today yeah yeah let's see what she means
by trunk full oh I got it so the kids
want to have a water balloon fight so
when I say go that's when everybody's
gonna go for them honestly she totally
exaggerated when she said it was for
easy mess 6:00 p.m. on the 13th
yeah 6:30 would be great
hi Kristin my name is Andrea I'm helping
us in an appointment you got it
it's just like between playing with them
and the messes and the appointments
I mean I'm handling it but it hats off
you know Tony Tony's got a lot you know
you're always asking me to do more me be
more and go bigger so this is you going
big this is me going bigger for you I
wanted to do something special because
you take extremely good care of me and
the kids
this is sweet I'm glad you love the
surprise I love you
I really enjoyed providing the help that
I had to Tony so I just overall it was a
great positive day more than anything I
just had a really fun time but my one of
my favorite things that we did that I
used to do with my old boss is prank
somebody Mitchell my coworker you didn't
even realize it was happening I felt
like it was something that we kind of
got to bond over and I can't I really
can't say thank you enough I really
really really from the bottom my heart
um appreciate everything that you did
for me and I know it seems like
something that you do all the time for
other people but it felt really special
for somebody to do that for me and thank
you oh you're so wonderful
but yeah I'd say things are going pretty
good so far um where are you going
where's she going